est-ce que vous pensez que la France va
mourir
bonsoir
alors Karine bonsoir vous êtes une une
jeune artiste de 23 ans avec des
origines grecques et espagnols danseuse
vous êtes comédienne vous êtes chanteuse
et fait vos premiers concerts à l'âge de
16 ans voilà et vous Bonnie Tyler vous
avez toujours refusé de réenregistrer
vos grands tubes pourquoi vous avez
accepté cette fois avec Karine
Antonio
et je me suis dit
je vais changer d'avis parce que ça
marche bien toutes les deux en tout cas
je pense et pourquoi pourquoi
19e
et pourquoi elle
regardez là elle a 23 ans c'est un petit
peu comme si j'étais sa mère alors je ne
sais pas pourquoi je l'ai choisi vous
êtes un petit peu amoureuse d'elle non
je ne suis pas lesbienne désolé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est sûr mais ça ne dépend pas du
nombre d'années ce qu'il faut écouter
vraiment c'est la voix c'est tout ce
qu'il y a d'importance pour moi la voix
je n'aurais pas fait ce duo avec
quelqu'un qui n'avait pas une voix aussi
spéciale et particulière que Karine vous
connaissiez Bonnie Tyler avant vous
connaissez juste la chanson ah non moi
Bonnie Tyler ça a été une rencontre
assez particulière parce que je me
souviens encore d'elle dans des clips je
devais avoir 4-5 ans et quand je l'ai vu
j'ai été
tu vas bien lui remonter le moral
je l'ai revu j'allais justement dire un
truc sympa j'ai été choquée parce qu'en
fait j'ai revu le vraiment le visage
dont je me souvenais dans le clip et
elle a pas bougé quoi c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
en tous les cas vous avez l'air de bien
vous avez l'air de bien vous entendre
toutes les deux là hein
on a tourné ce clip au Canada on vient
de rentrer c'était génial on va passer
une super semaine plein de choses
alors dans votre dernier album qui a
rien à voir avec ce que vous avez fait
avec Karine Anton il y a une reprise de
in my life des Beatles
enregistré le dernier album avec le
Philharmonic de Prague c'est vrai que
j'ai repris une chanson des Beatles de
YouTube Richard Marx
toutes ces vieilles chansons vous savez
avec mon groupe et un orchestre
philharmonique et c'est quelque chose
qui a eu du succès dans certains pays
d'Europe ça a été un très grand succès
mais bon ce n'est pas grave moi j'ai pas
l'impression qu'il faut absolument que
je sois au top des parade pour pour être
heureuse je crois que ce qui est
important c'est que je fasse quelque
chose qui me plaît
je travaille je chante et c'est ce qui
m'intéresse
in my life vous vous connaissez les
paroles
j'adore votre voix vous avez une voix un
peu comme Rod Stewart
[Musique]
de champagne mais bon c'est un peu
particulier ce soir on a fait la fête
merci
[Musique]
Emmanuel voulait vous aimez Bonnie Tyler
vous voulez chanter quelque chose
d'autre avant de partir parce que moi
j'adore quand vous chantez ouais
[Applaudissements]
un peu trop non
mais pourquoi pourquoi est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas chanter
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous pensez que la France va
mourir
parce que
les deux tu les boules
elle est en plein essor 19
ça encore là tu sais avec ça
vous habitez en France
[Rires]
je ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire mais
bon et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu